[Music]
Duterte made a token attempt to increase
capacity by building a mega rehab
facility on a military base about four
hours north of Manila our crew is the
first ever to be allowed inside to film
it's a big complex divided into four
four phases each face can occupy a
maximum 2,500 patients I know no other
Center in the world that has the same
capacity or the same logistical means
not entirely sure this has been
reinforced it I mean the whole thing is
just they're doing their best but this
is held together very carefully to say
the least
my to reconsider going up those stairs
as I seen this first the entire
structure is just kind of floating
Christ they built this in three months
they don't dissolve and really in three
months yeah these are all prefab expect
but this is a temporary facility that at
the end of the day when the facilities
are no longer needed they can be given
to the military for whatever persons
they may commit necessary six years they
need
you don't have it it could be here is
the length of a president's term right
yeah just pick that number out of thin
air there it's up its up to the next
administration what a continuous so on
one hand a 10,000 bed mega rehab
facility is undoubtedly a good thing
especially when compared to the violent
alternatives but on the other it's a
patchwork solution it's a band-aid and
they said as much they're building it on
the fly kind of popsicle sticks and
chewing gum even at full capacity this
facility will only address the needs of
a few for every addict admitted there
are still a hundred on the streets
fearing for their lives
[Music]
Oh